the tray lance off the board the atlanta
falcons did not have a difficult
decision to make it number four they had
been connected to lance as a possible
future quarterback post matt ryan
instead they go with tight end kyle
pitts a guy who is regarded as a
transcendent talent their best tight end
since tony gonzalez potentially better
than tony gonzalez time will tell but
pitts was regarded as a can't miss
prospect
juices up that passing game and also
will continue to invite speculation that
the falcons will be looking for a trade
partner so that they can unload the
julio jones contract remember it's a
15.3 million dollar guaranteed salary
for 2021 he could be traded
at any time in principle it would be a
deal that goes into effect after june
one having pits makes it easier to move
on because they still have calvin ridley
if they do keep julio jones that's a
pretty formidable offense between jones
and ridley and pitts bottom line pitts
great tight end prospect now in atlanta
falcon he'll play with matt ryan at
least for a year or two and he gives the
falcons a chance to get a lot better on
offense in the first year of the arthur
smith regime
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports